[Música]
bueno buenas noches mi nombre es mario
soto correa soy estudiante de 12 del
colombo
hoy les voy a cantar dos canciones la
primera seguramente la conocen tiene una
letra hermosa y probablemente algunos
aquí se han sentido como yo o se sienten
quién sabe identificados con su letra
porque del despecho amoroso poquitos se
salvan entonces junto a un gran pianista
william gonzález esta canción se llama
obsesión de peter manjarrés
[Aplausos]
[Música]
que dice tu mirada
qué cosa extraña tus ojos tienen cuando
miro tu foto una rara obsesión me
detiene dios mío tú que eres el creador
de todas las cosas más bellas que hay en
el punto porque no escuchas mis
peticiones
[Música]
de coss para todos los males pero por
qué no inventaste uno que pueda curar un
mal día
[Música]
en la tierra girar al revés para hacerme
pequeño y volver a nacer
[Música]
y no tener que volver a extrañarte en tu
fotografía mirarte y llevarte fundido en
mi pecho como si fueras parte de mi
barranquilla ciudad de cantores de
vallenatos y de acordeones en la adorna
a tus calles de cine que deseo que sea
feliz que es la última canción que
compongo que no creo volver a enamorarme
pero dime como insiste negro a olvidarte
de mí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la gente me critica porque ahora ya no
soy parrandera con tu partida negro
siento más frío muero el silencio
recuerdo mes de julio tus cumpleaños te
juro que trato y no he podido cantando
pero no puedo
cuida de mis retoños porque tú sabes que
yo los quiero dios mío dame fuerzas para
curar un mal
[Música]
no tierras mirar atrás
para hacerme pequeno y volver a nacer
y no tener que volver a extrañarte y en
tu fotografía mirarte y llevarte fundido
en mi pecho como si fueras parte de mi
barranquilla ciudad de cantores de
vallenatos y de acordeones en la dorna
tus calles decide que deseo que sea
y esta última canción que compongo que
no creo volver a enamorarme
como existe negro
a olvidarte de mí
muchas gracias
ahí me enredé un poquito con la letra
pero bueno
bueno yo empecé a cantar a los 7 años la
primera presentación que tuve en mi vida
fue en esta misma tarima
y poco sabía yo en ese entonces que esa
primera presentación sería la primera de
muchas y que eventualmente llevaría un
sueño y a una voz a una vocación que me
asusta como me apasiona este es el sueño
de dedicarme al teatro musical o sea
canto baile y actuación
en noviembre de 2017 el colegio hizo una
adaptación musical de la película a la
danza para el cual tuvo el placer de
hacer el papel protagónico femenino
entonces ahora les voy a cantar una
canción de ese personaje junto a el
excelente pianista de william gonzález
por favor un aplauso para williams
[Aplausos]
y esta canción es una que toca cada
fibra de mi cuerpo porque habla de un
tema con el que yo y estoy segura que
muchos otros y no solamente artistas se
pueden identificar se pueden relacionar
y este es el tema de los sueños los
sueños
que parecen descabellados locos que a
veces se sienten imposibles o
inalcanzables
pero que eso hace que los deseemos y los
apreciamos aún más esta canción se llama
adhesión del sur jim de la lnd
mayáns y esto de ventajas
remember existe como juventud te
lesionaste horizontal
en el presente
hay un éxito desde dentro de river
cuidado lo que
[Música]
antxon bote
no se dan
guarda más fluida y chris pitman
smishing puede ser chic
a quién
[Música]
cristian bucci
funes
sí
de nadie
más
güímar
sic a percibir sky windows y la de
sunseri
si le llega en la ue áfrica
esto fue
cristian bucci
moody's
sí
[Música]
hoy
daré
este mes we make
[Música]
pero decís que
si quiero poder decir
[Música]
somos dos rabos de los problemas de
princesa
y mucho
louis digas de meis y
cristiada
de nuevo
[Música]
ciudad
no deseen
[Música]
tú
sí sí
[Música]
aquí
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias